back
from a mission of national security
this is a government drone used to track
down and capture illegal crossings
on the english channel these aircraft
play a vital role in protecting our
borders and helping to convict people
traffickers
sky news has been given unprecedented
access
to see for the first time the ongoing
operations
led by the home office we're seeking to
achieve that balance through these
incredible
uh cutting-edge aircraft that are
gathering images
from the moment the uh the boats are in
french waters
right up to the coast of the uk we're
gathering evidence for prosecution and
intelligence
as well as preserving knives and what
we're finding is that
every single one of these boats of
course has to be piloted by somebody
and if you're that person you can expect
when you arrive in the uk to be arrested
and prosecuted and go to jail
inside the control room we witness
pilots scouring the calm open waters of
the channel
and like so often the drone is first to
spot vulnerable small boats
often packed with people a lot of the
time we do detect
these vessels coming across that
unaccounted for and no one is aware of
and as soon as we do
it you know it's our job to report it
straight back to dover so we do that we
don't
uh hesitate we don't stutter um it is
what we're tasked to do and we're all
very experienced people are doing that
what's happening at this airfield is a
rare sight
a commercial drone company working
alongside the ministry of defence
on national security there are clear
efforts
that the long-standing illegal crossings
are being tackled
on the ground on sea and now
from the air and one evidence gathering
mission
played a vital role in a successful
prosecution
in july a home office drone captured
this footage
of a man steering a small boat with 20
migrants on board
heading for the uk reboi ahmed now faces
31 months in prison
for assisting unlawful immigration
he is just one of over 6 000 people so
far who've taken the dangerously
desperate journey
from french shores onto ours one day
alone
more than 400 people crossed in small
boats it's why the military
has also been deployed so this is a long
endurance
uas it's basically there to
bring us two sensors the first is a
camera the second is a radar
and we can use both those sensors to
identify what's happening
obviously across the english channel
beam that through live inventory back to
the coast guard
to aid their understanding in terms of
finding
and prioritizing the the vessels that we
see
clearly the uk government are investing
more resources
in trying to disrupt traffickers but
many are still escorting hundreds of
people
across one of the world's busiest
shipping lanes the french too
are yet to play a full part in this
endeavor if they allow these drones to
operate on their shores
it could stop migrants entering the
water altogether
this would be a major step in protecting
lives and the uk's borders
interman rasheed sky news